this is the correct version of the Iron
Throne yeah I mean I state repeatedly in
the book that the iron stone is you huge
they did towers over the room like a
great beast and it's ugly it's
asymmetric it it's it was put together
by blacksmiths not by craftsmen and
experts in furniture manufacturer and
you have to walk up iron steps and when
a king sits on it he's like 10 feet
above everybody else in a hole so he's
in this raised position looking down on
him and the hole itself is is huge and
is made of the swords of the defeated
enemies the throne the throne is made of
this all the swords you know when during
Aegon's conquest when people surrendered
to them they they sat down their sword
as a series of submission and of course
when he won a battle by burning
everybody there were all these burned
melted swords lying around so he
gathered all of them up and he gave them
and said make a throne out of this and
that's what they did and it's a it's a
sign of dominance and conquest and when
you stand before it you're supposed to
remember that you know look on my works
ye mighty and despair was a little bit
of the of the psychology of that but
nobody ever got it right I mean there
were comic book versions and there were
versions in the card game and then and
the board gamer they were versions on
the cover and there were versions that
were done for conventions you know the
very first there was a wooden one that I
sat on in 1996 at the at the ABA that
looked like the emboss version on their
first edition silver book but none of
them were ever really right the closest
one who ever came was was Marv simonetti
two French artists and even his first
one wasn't right but since he was a
closest I worked with him and then we
got him for this book and he and I went
back a half-dozen times
to finally get something I could say
yeah this is this is absolutely right
now of course you can't do this in the
TV show it's not something I criticize
HBO for or something like that I mean
the Thrones they have
enormous ly large and cumbersome to move
and expensive to build to build this
monstrosity would would blow the budget
of an entire episode and it wouldn't fit
in the set I mean our throne room our
throne room is is in the paint Hall and
belt in Belfast in Northern Ireland not
a paint hole is the largest some stage
in Europe it was a originally part of
the old Harland and Wolff shipyard where
they built the Titanic and they painted
the the ship's the hulls of the ships in
this hole which gives you the idea of
the scale of it and we've divided it
into a number of pods and our throne
room is in one of them and it's a very
large set but it's not large enough you
would need Saint Paul's Cathedral if
they would give us st. Paul's Cathedral
or Westminster Abbey to shoot in and a
year to build a giant throne like that
of that would dominate the entire thing
and go half way to the ceiling then you
could get the Iron Throne the way it's
described in the books but this is the
difference between books and television
you know I can I can say well that the
wall is 700 feet high but I don't
actually have the build a 7-foot 150
wall or a giant throne made of made of
nasty-looking swords here it's
interesting there's actually a terrific
speech that Littlefinger gives in in
last season where he talks about the
iron throne made from a thousand thrones
of ngons enemies and then he said I
counted him once and really there's only
137 then you know it's the one truth is
truth and legend disagree parental
legend and it's an interesting speech
that's true in the show but it's not
true in the books because it really are
the thousands of swords in the real Iron
Throne the the gigantic iron throne it's
it's that's it's in King's Landing in
the books it reminds me a little bit of
Tamerlane was supposedly made a huge
pile of his defeated enemies skulls a
Zamani
to his greatness and that's what this
has always reminded me of it's great to
see it you know it was a tradition among
many conquerors the deep pyramid of
skulls it's you know one of those things
you can always go back to the old are
good
[Laughter]